so assessing the situation are they
breathing
no rows they are not breathing
and they have no arms or legs no that's
not part of it
where are they you know what if we come
across somebody
with no arms or legs do we bother
resuscitating them
i mean what kind of quality of life do
we have there i would want to live with
no legs
how about no arms no arms or legs is
basically how you exist right now kevin
you don't do anything
all right well let's get back to it
because you're losing them
okay too fast everyone we need to pump
at a pace of 100 beats per minute
oh okay that's uh hard to keep track how
many is that per hour
how's that going to help you i will
divide and then count to it right
okay well a good trick is to pump to the
tune of staying alive by the bee gees do
you know that song yes yes
i do i love that song first i was afraid
i was petrified
no it's a
uh staying alive you were in the parking
lot earlier that's how i know you
ah staying alive
staying alive
since i was born when it's all right
it's okay
you
yeah okay you didn't maintain 100 beats
per minute and the ambulance didn't
arrive because nobody called 9-1-1
so you lost him okay he's dead anyone
know what we do next anybody
rose i have no idea anyone else we bury
him
wrong and check for an organ donor card
if he has one we only have minutes to
harvest he has no
wallet i checked he is an organ donor he
is yeah give me some ice in a styrofoam
bucket
here we go
we search for the organs where's the
heart the brush is hard i'm not feeling
well i need to sit down
are you okay
oh my god oh my god
can you tell me why you had to cut the
face off the dummy
i didn't think it was very realistic in
the movie and it turns out
it's pretty realistic can i just give my
case to hitchcock and scully and they
clearly have a ton of time on their
hands
hitchcock hasn't even gotten out of his
chair today hey jay
i can go anywhere in this thing but
shouldn't where are you on digitizing
the old case files
as of yesterday i'm officially one
percent done
why are you smiling that's nothing oh
there's thousands of cases and for each
one i have to fill out 200 little box
thingies on 50 different screens at
least you get to sit on your butt all
day
that's actually the worst part my doctor
said i have an anal canyon
scully why are you always telling us
about your disgusting body
i don't see anything that's because it's
all wort
how are you married welcome to animal
control
let me show you around those are some
chairs that's a cat or a possum
oh this is a napkin where i wrote down a
cool name for a dog
bark obama right is that
what's happening here oh yo yeah we
found this bird outside
we tried to turn it into a work whistle
like in the beginning of the flintstones
tougher than it looked though we have a
massive pest problem in this town and
it's because the animal control
department has been a disaster
at catching animals they're great at
ingesting and selling
marijuana this place is a miserable suck
hole run by two pothead losers
it's completely and utterly mismanaged
thanks
it does seem to be very poorly run but
we've only been here for two minutes
there may be a method to their madness
there's more than one way to skin a cat
four there's four ways to skin a cat
ready
what is this coyote trap dude this hurts
yeah we got like a huge vermin problem i
mean we've been meaning to call somebody
about it but you know nobody get on the
phone
you're the people you would be calling
that is so trippy
ow you're fired you're fired the whole
department is fired oh this hurts this
was one of my running feet
yo let's go to jamaica no we should go
to jamaica oh is that what you said
morning boss you want a little touch-up
before we
dennis roll it i got a new take
okay uh yeah
good morning whitlock high here's the
morning announcements in your face
oh guess what's for lunch today pizza
with a side order of hepatitis a
cafeteria food sucks right
you know who else has hepatitis a jeremy
jones
[Music]
jeremy will be spending some time at
children's hospital
so everybody sign the big card we love
you jeremy
oh my god a huge celebrity just dropped
by
yo what's up it's snoop doggy dog
get your tickets to the sadie hawkins
dance i think that's blackface
uh self-defense
is not some fun boxing match okay this
is about escaping with your life
so strike scream
and run all right let's try it
that may have been my fault what the
hell toby everybody listen up i have an
important visitor coming today and i
would appreciate it if you could act
with a little bit of dignity
and treat me like i've got some
authority oh thank you
you have got to relax oh morgan morgan
why are you unsopping wet
because i just went to the bathroom do
you know that the water in the toilet is
actually cleaner than the water in the
sink
i it is no i read it on
the internet i read a whole article
about it who is sandra where is that
all right nassandra it it says here
that you want to kill a co-worker named
carol
yeah oh oh sandra i understand
when i'm frustrated i want to wring
someone's neck
exactly bring it hard so what do you do
what do you do when that feeling comes
over you
well i put on a hoodie that covers my
face
and i take the 47 bus line to a library
in a far away town
then i open a private browser on one of
their computers
and google home thinking of killing her
to see what mistakes people usually make
jesus oh what are you doing to my hair
you stay away from my frank
who is with my frank katie you zebia
please let me explain
what is this
eat your vegetables
damn k that is weak i'm a 40-year-old
man
you think i'm gonna be scared into
eating some stuff
i'm a because
[Applause]
you